I've had to do what I have least wanted to do, and that is taking the medication that
can squally for hormone-based cancer, which is what knocks your estrogen levels down.
I was doing great with little side effects due to the protocol to lessen due to the protocol,
to lessen them. My antigen numbers have had now raised me for four months. I'm assuming that you're
talking about your two marker numbers have been rising for four months. Yet, the CT scan says
that the cancer is stable. I did a negolase test to confirm one or the other. How reliable
is the negolase test or what other test do you recommend? So, I think like any test,
there's no test is perfect, so there's imperfection on any test. So, if my
negolase numbers were stable, but my tumor markers were elevated, and my CT scan was stable.
You've got to balance that with how are you feeling subjectively? Are there any other signs
of metastasis? Are you having any pain anywhere? Is the CT scan that was done? Was it a regional CT scan?
Did you look at other places? Have you done a PET scan? What are your other blood tests look like?
And what are the blood tests? What are the blood tests that you look at?
Honestly, as many blood tests, they're willing to do. Certainly, the complete metabolic test,
you're going to be looking at the most, you know, you're going to be looking at liver markers
most closely, I would say. Signs, which has to assist to bode with liver markers would be elevated
alkaline phosphatase and elevated calcium level. You're looking, looking for signs of anemia
complete metabolic code. So, are there any other perfect tests to help diagnose
cancer? You could look at a Pradovo scan. That's a whole body MRI scan that is not using contrast
eyes. If you want to avoid doing a PET scan, otherwise a PET scan. So, look at some of those things to
confirm, you know, the direction of your care. Those are things you want to look at.